99% of the food in the UK regarding the
curries are all from North India Delhi I
don't know what we're doing the UK's an
insult to what did you overhear
I'm not complete with the level of
Indian food that I know Delhi is the
eighth largest metropolis in the world
with 17 million residents my issue is
are we doing it wrong are we faking it
and Delhi's gonna give me my answer so
my mission in northern India is a
personal culinary voyage of discovery
all the classics such as Brogan Josh
Brioni and butter chicken come from here
in the 19th century workers in the
British Raj acquired a taste for curry
creating a demand for it upon the
returns of Britain and we've been in
love with Indian food
ever since India is a big mystery to me
so the Wacky Races unbelievable I've
never been doing it before and I have to
say it's quite a shock to the system
amazing extraordinary I mean kids
everywhere we're actually living on the
street I need a bit of guidance I'm on
my way to meet someone who can help have
one of India's most famous restaurants
the moti maja
it's here UK favorite such as tandoori
chicken were invented
Seema Chandra is an expert on the food
of northern India and she's helping me
with my travel itinerary I know how are
you very well
good to see Maya
very happy to be here she's one of
India's most respected food writers and
restaurant critics why have you brought
me here
well the reason I got to here is that
this place is where most of Indian food
the way it's known the world over yeah
they all began here I love mo Mali the
dark chicken tikka yes wait but the
chicken started right here 60 years ago
seriously is there a difference between
what they're serving here - what we're
serving in the UK it is nothing he knows
what you're gonna get you I mean I was
shocked that they even call it Indians
me if I'd have a problem with it it's
not Indian green and they put sugar into
everything yeah anything okay that's it
that's done it's not Indians shall we
order so we'd like butter chicken of
course butter chicken tandoori chicken
so you moon convinced that I'm gonna
take the big difference to what I'm
about to eat out and out thank you okay
thank you are you gonna eat with your
with a knife and fork you tell me gon
get the favorite of Indian food with a
knife and fork no I should try that back
your homeboys finish it's blasphemous
what do you think it's absolutely
delicious and it's not it's not dying
its moist its moisture that's the dish
you've been reading for so the butter
chicken this is in
knotti help it is nothing gives me more
pleasure than seeing someone you dancing
bloody hell
how does this compare with what you have
I mean that already mr. Siemer it's
chalk and cheese it's very flavor 'some
yeah and there's no it doesn't taste
change charter Jerry's not like he's
been laced with some accurate no I don't
fresh tomatoes